my my four hours in Portugal were
amazing just in and out hardcore just an
amazing country that I wish I got to
spend a little more time in but you'll
see the chaos and tomorrow is the first
original weekend dailyvee which I'm
filming right now it's a little preview
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
I'm supposed to be onstage in 20 minutes
yes I'm the kid on the keynote speaker I
have to carry banners here yeah yeah
he's he's with me is well I've got our
girl together we did it I'll do
something I'm in good shape
yeah I just got off a flight yeah yeah
it's nice Jack
I gots frog ha ha ha
thank God I woke up today that's my
rules out that Lee had to mix it you
have to deal with the reality of the
situation
dwelling and pondering and crying
doesn't do [ __ ] and it especially
doesn't do [ __ ] in this eco chamber in
this arena there is no crying you can
cry you're just gonna lose and I'm bad
news about complaining and crying let me
tell you something about complaining and
crying that's really really gonna hurt
for all you complainers out there nobody
gives a [ __ ] it's here it's upon us and
now we have to more than ever we have to
start deploying self awareness if you
leave here and start your process of
really knowing what makes you happy if
you want to actually do something even
in the light of the picture that I'm
painting right now who are you scared to
fail in front of the reason so many of
you are not doing what you want to do is
you're scared you're scared that your
brother will judge you your wife your
girlfriend your husband and most scary
your mom or your dad you need to
eliminate that and/or own that fear and
put yourself in a position to succeed
and a lot of people need to hear one of
two things today which is this is the
greatest era to ever be alive and be an
entrepreneur executive if you want it
and
stop complaining and dwelling cuz nobody
gives a [ __ ]
thank you yes Oakland ah could you
imagine who there's good one oh we're
going to a whole different place yeah
Drive you over there go back and look at
what happened in the late 40s and early
50s when our society went away from
being a primary television society to an
emerging television society a lot of
people a lot of power a lot of brands
died and a lot of emerged and that's
what we're about to live through over
this next decade as we shift to the
phone being our primary news content
information platform we will have people
that are romantic and holding on to the
old world and they'll die and we'll have
new people that execute and storytelling
a new platform and emerge as more
important figures organizations and
causes because every time there's
something new we have an inability as
people to apply historic rules to it and
we're scared of the new thing we go into
defense again this is what we did on TV
forever and back to vine what
tell you about the 50 people that went
all-in on vine they're making millions
of dollars a year on branded content on
snapchat and Instagram they made a good
call while you debated if it was going
to be around
[Music]
[Applause]
Antonia meteor give you a picture you
[ __ ] put me let's go
you seen I said I gotta go I'm sorry
sorry fast fast let's go
I looked at your face I made me sad dang
awesome
Jack baby thank you thank you thank you
so much hi guys no this is this King hey
man yeah dude it's so clear it's getting
so crazy
it snuck in hi honey it'll Humphrey guy
I just get your suitcase I'm gonna be
late for my flight
I'm sorry man I'm so sorry come on run
yes yes yes that's not cool this come on
all right
can can tell them to stop for one second
thank you Gary you're welcome um real
fast
Oh awesome hi oh thank you so much I
love you I love you thank you so much
you take care taking my friends from
boarding you - no worries poor course
let's do it
great presentation you're welcome - man
what an amazing experience you gave us
awesome - hi guys all together all
together you look beautiful yes my water
you can cut him out all right stop it
happy thank you do something about it
okay it works for success root you're
gonna die I did that one so maybe it's
patience now you're young when you're
young all of you guys [ __ ] up because
you want it so bad too soon
I didn't do I [ __ ] work 20 hours a
day until I was 30 and then talk to
anybody just waited thank you you guys
wanted today yes you gotta wait you're
not coming are you continuing anyway I'm
double your age like you live a whole
nother [ __ ] life and you're my age
and you want a tomorrow you got kind of
real work you have to come up with some
idea do you think that will work the
knowledge that do you think the knows
that you get it that in university you
will be helpful in the real world no you
go but if you want to get a job yeah but
not if your problems is Lawrence I
[ __ ] it with Rowe alright right ready
thank you you're welcome guys take care
what's that your I need a second he's
coming right okay is there any space to
meet Matt this guy's sister doesn't have
her passport stuff that we got to throw
them in the car somehow
bye guys ask your questions wallet
one second
[Music]